thanks to you gov for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
a dark mysterious object has appeared at
the outer edges of our solar system
it looks like the remnants of a Dying
star but it behaves like a black hole
your mission traveling right into its
Heart of Darkness
what makes this mysterious object unique
how dangerous would it be to experience
such powerful gravity
and how might this turn into one of the
strangest experiences in the universe
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a black neutron
star
I know we've talked about black holes
before but let me do a quick recap
a black hole isn't much different from
any other object with mass except that
it's really really dense
all the matter it contains is compressed
into one point called a singularity
which is so small and so dense that our
understanding of time and space within
it breaks down
that Singularity is what causes black
holes to have enormous gravity
and then there are neutron stars
these form when a large star collapses
at the end of its Stellar life
a star that was once one and a half
times more massive than our own Sun
would now only be about 20 kilometers
wide that's no bigger than a city
but what you have lurking on the
outskirts of the solar system is
something else entirely
too massive to be a neutron star too
small to be a black hole
this is a black neutron star
not much is known about these objects
and what we do know you're about to
learn the hard way
this lesson might be a tough one but
there are some things you have to
experience to understand fully and once
you have that knowledge then you can
pass on your opinions and experiences to
others like you can on yougov if you
haven't heard of yougov well let me fill
you in it's an exciting site that allows
you to earn cash and gift cards by
sharing your opinion that's right you
can take online surveys and polls on
politics pop culture products and Brands
and actually get paid there's no cost to
sign up and you can do the surveys
anytime I like to do my surveys while
I'm on the train yeah this life hack
pays off in the long run look it's super
easy to get started and you can do this
anywhere and anytime how amazing is that
I've already redeemed the gift card and
taken my family to lunch hey your
opinions matter so why not get paid for
them click the link below and take
surveys to earn cash on yougov today
let your voice be heard now because if
you wait too long you might be screaming
into the void
for this scenario Let's ignore the fact
that it would take you thousands of
years to travel all the way to the
outskirts of the solar system let's
imagine that the best scientists on the
planet came up with a way to roam our
planetary neighborhood really fast
and now you'd be observing this
gravitational monster up close
you'd know exactly where a black neutron
star was making its catastrophic
approach because of all the radiation it
emits
this is the same way you'd find either
black hole or a neutron star and just
getting close enough to observe this
star won't be enough
you need to venture right into its
Center
your mission would require some
protective gear and this gear would need
to keep you safe from some of the most
intense forces of gravity in the
universe
so don't take this preparation lightly
the black neutron star would be pulling
you toward it with gravity about 2
billion times stronger than what you're
used to on Earth
the problem is that the kind of intense
gravity protection gear you need doesn't
exist without it your mission would be
of the suicidal variety
as you got closer different parts of
your body would experience different
gravity
if you were diving into this monstrosity
head first your upper body would get
stretched a lot more than your legs
as you got closer to its Center you'd be
spaghettified
yeah you'd become long and thin from
your head down to your toes just like
spaghetti only this would be one
brutally painful plate of pasta
but since you'd be on an incredibly
important Mission you'd have the best
equipment you could ever imagine
the best NASA scientists would Supply
you with a suit resistant to the extreme
pressures temperatures and radioactive
matter inside the black neutron star
now would be the time for the task at
hand
you dive layer by layer into an object
of incredible Mass
it would be like falling into our sun if
it was squeezed into the size of a small
City
on the outside the black neutron star
would look like any other kind of star
except that it would be really toasty
your regular neutron stars are extremely
hot usually about 1 million degrees
Celsius a black neutron star well you'd
have to find out its temperature on your
own
I bet it would be just as scorching
first you pass through a gaseous layer
of hydrogen and helium
after that you'd find yourself on more
solid ground
scientists think that the second layer
would likely be composed of iron and
silicon to continue your mission you
need to somehow punch through this
blazing solid surface
well lucky for you NASA equipped you
with a super powerful drill that can
withstand the Heat
and things would start getting
dangerously dense
I hope those guys at Nasa made you an
extremely durable suit too
down at the heart of the black neutron
star you'd notice a unique material one
of the strangest in the universe
scientists call it nuclear pasta
inside the neutron star the nuclear
clusters get packed so densely that they
create the hardest matter ever known
at least this time it's not you that's
turned into spaghetti if all this talk
about you being turned into some sort of
food item has you worried well brace
yourself the madness would just be
getting started
now you'd be so deep that the intense
levels of pressure around you would be
about three times higher than the
density of an atomic nucleus protons and
electrons would combine into neutrons
hey well now you know how neutron stars
got their name
as these newly formed neutrons start to
overlap more and more you'd keep
traveling further and further down
eventually you'd find yourself face to
face with the squished components of
neutrons and protons quarks
finally approaching the core of the
black neutron star you'd be nearing
maximum bizarreness
of all the squishy quarks surrounding
you there would be some so weird that
scientists call them strange quarks
these quarks are heavier than other
quarks and they've earned their name by
possessing a property known as
strangeness
all it means is that strange quarks have
less chance of being torn apart by the
black neutron stars electromagnetism
inside this core the strange quarks
would form a soupy mixture known simply
as Strange Matter
and encountering Strange Matter would be
the very end of the journey for you
Strange Matter is contagious that means
when it comes into contact with ordinary
matter like you it would generate more
Strange Matter so as soon as you touch
it it would instantly dissolve your
protective gear and immediately after
that your whole body
maybe it would have been better to avoid
all this strangeness and fall into a
regular black hole instead well that's a
story
for another
what if
thanks again to you gov for sponsoring
this video